I'm lucky enough to get the day off on
this national holiday what better way to
spend this beautiful day than with my
favorite girl essentials water bath
water bottle water bottle water bottle
tennis ball snacks school bags
sunglasses also got a throw on Roxy's
whistle three to keep her healthy and
safe but more on that later
yeah nice to meet you hey Mike
so I just got an alert from the whistle
three app that Roxie left her safe zone
and this is a predetermined safe zone
that the app allows you to set for Roxy
to have an extra layer of security I'm
gonna go and get a cup of coffee all
right so you hang out here all right
I'll be right back stay
[Music]
good job let's go are you ready
it's dog park time welcome no you just
lick ple crazy go get it bring it bring
it bring it bring it
[Music]
think about all the benefits are for
Roxy to run around reducing the risk of
obesity reducing the risk of all these
chronic diseases Roxy anxiety is
drastically reduced when she's running
around like this if you have a dog
that's tearing stuff up at home you have
a dog that's always barking maybe you
don't just needs a little exercise and
it's a little anxious because it has too
much energy Oh get to talk get to
talking about so I'm just checking my
whistle 3 app and it basically acts as
an activity tracker to tell me if Roxy's
got enough exercise for the day it's
pretty awesome
[Music]
Roxy hi hi nice to meet you
Mariana this is Roxy a lot of New
Yorkers don't come to Times Square
because they think that there's too many
tourists there's too much foot traffic
but personally this is my favorite part
of the city
I don't live too far away but I always
like to come through here and really get
a sense of what's going on in the world
Roxy likes it here she gets a lot of
exposure of food people so it really
helps her calm down and ease her anxiety
when there's a lot of things going on
this is what makes New York City special
the fact that we have all these
different cultures all these different
people coming all together in one area
Laura we can't see you but we're trying
to say hi to you
[Music]
I love taking Roxy on car rides but man
her hair this shedding if I have the
windows open I'm not even joking it's in
my mouth
[Music]
we're gonna take Roxy to Staten Island
her hometown
[Music]
trailing our car probably looks so
strange there's like hair flooding out
the windows
that is the eastern seaboard of the
United States Europe Staten Island is
often referred to as a Forgotten borough
but I went to high school here so this
thing you don't forgot Burrell for me
Staten Island Staten and welcome to
another beautiful New York City Park
Rock Scott let's go explore we have our
guide
what's cool about Roxy is yes I trained
her off leash but that's a command to
come back she actually will go ahead of
us see the trail and then not go forward
and literally turn around and wait for
us to catch up
you wouldn't think this is in the middle
of Staten Island like this by the way
this is ten miles all right so we're in
the middle of this beautiful dense
forest with a little rock sea monster
what happens if Roxy runs away what if a
deer comes out and she starts running
and I can't stop her well guess what I
have that little gadget around her neck
to whistle three that allows me to start
this feature on my phone called track
Roxy the feature is called track
whatever your dog's name is the GPS
satellite connects to the little gadget
or out of your neck
and gives me updates on the map where
roxy is and when it does that I can get
Roxy back Roxy come on come on puppy
good girl what a good girl good girl
I got a splinter that would've been a
dangerous Bluebird Rock sleep Roxy
get out of there eels look what's on her
face she's dug her face into the rabbit
hole
yeah we've conquered Deer Park in Staten
Island Oh shake good girl dude I don't
even have paper towels what do you do
with no paper towels in a dirty dog come
on Kevin I think Roxy was such a great
little pups today that she deserves a
treat she likes these these empty ones
hi Roxy you have to pick between the Fox
the rabbit and the duck which one of
these do you want you want a duck one
the chicken
nope Roxy any toy you want get anything
you want you like oh yeah you're
thinking about we have a winner okay
let's go get you this toy last thing
we're gonna do before we go home is I'm
gonna surprise my dad and we're gonna
stop by the house he doesn't know that
rocks he's coming but I'm gonna get him
to come outside Roxy's gonna sprint at
him like a maniac holes watch rocks you
who is that go go go go go go go go go
go she's too happy to be home come on in
my childhood home welcome welcome kids
yeah do you get another one say hi to
the YouTube community hi YouTube
community say it
I do commune - thank you all right guys
this is my childhood picture and don't
judge me
look at that guy
look at that champ right there let's
mean my sister
love you but they like me
just got back from our trip all across
New York City with little rocks a Monsta
but I could actually see all of roxies
activity it's pretty cool she really
wants all across New York City today
huge shout out to whistle for sponsoring
this video and partnering with me and
Roxy if you like the little gadget
that's around her neck the link is down
in the description box
use code Roxy to get 25% off and I hope
you learned something about dogs about
New York City about your own health and
you enjoy spending the day with me and
Roxy down what better way to Roxy what
are you doing what are you doing huh
speak
[Music]
you